>>> WELCOME BACK.
WANTO SHOW YOU LIVE PICTURES
RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE TWO
GRANDSONS OF THE LATE QUEEN
ELIZABETH ALONG WITH THEIR WIVES
AND NOW SONS OF KING CHARLES
III.
THEY'RE AT WINDSOR CASTLE THERE
AND NOW LOOKING OVER ALL OF THE
BEAUTIFUL FLOWERS THAT HAVE BEEN
LEFT FOR THE MEMORY OF QUEEN
ELIZABETH II, JUST DAYS AFTER
HER PASSING.
AND NOW YOU'VE GOT THE PRINCE
AND PRINCESS OF WALES, WILLIAM
AND KATE, ALONG WITH PRINCE
HARRY AND THE DUCHESS, MEGHAN
THERE.
AND THEY'RE NOW ALL LOOKING
THROUGH AND JUST EARLIER TODAY,
YOU HAD THE SONS OF QUEEN
ELIZABETH AND THEIR CHILDREN WHO
WERE LOOKING THROUGH THE
FLOWERS, VERY INTIMATELY,
LEANING OVER, READING THE CARDS
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT, EVEN
TEARFULLY REFLECTING ON SOME OF
THE BEAUTIFUL NOTES THAT HAVE
BEEN LEFT IN MEMORY OF QUEEN
ELIZABETH.
AND ALL OF THIS HAPPENING AS
WE'RE ALSO STARTING TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE EVENTS THAT WILL
TAKE PLACE OVER THESE TEN DAYS
OF MOURNING.
WHERE THE QUEEN WILL LIE IN
STATE ON WEDNESDAY.
THE FAMILY, OF COURSE, WILL BE
THERE AND THEN THE DOORS WILL BE
OPEN FOR THE MASSES.
THE PUBLIC WHO WILL BE THERE TO
LINE UP TO SEE HER LYING IN
STATE.
AND NOW WE ALSO HAVE OFFICIALLY
A DATE OF THE FUNERAL WHICH WILL
BE MONDAY, SEPTEMBER 19th.
OUR SCOTT McCLAIN IS THERE AT
THE GATES OF WINDSOR.
SO, SCOTT, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING
THERE?
WE SEE IN THE BACKGROUND BEHIND
THE BARRICADES, HUGE CROWDS AND
NOW THEY ARE SEEING THE
GRANDSONS THERE, ALONG WITH
THEIR WIVES LOOKING THROUGH THE
FLOWERS AND THE CARDS.
>> THAT IS RIGHT, FREDRICKA.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, WHEN THESE
FOUR STEPPED OUT OF THEIR
VEHICLE, THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT ANYONE HAD EXPECTED.
WE WERE TOLD INITIALLY THAT
THERE WOULD BE A VISIT.
WE ASSUMED THAT THE TWO WORKING
ROYALS, WILLIAM AND KATE, THE
PRINCE AND PRINCESS OF WALES NOW
WOULD BE HERE.
WE DID NOT EXPECT TO SEE HARRY
AND MEGHAN.
AND WE CERTAINLY DIDN'T EXPECT
TO SEE THE FOUR OF THESE
TOGETHER, OF COURSE THERE HAS
BEEN A WELL-PUBLICIZED RIFT
WITHIN THE FAMILY BETWEEN THESE
TWO BROTHERS AND OF COURSE
MEGHAN AND HARRY HER HUSBAND,
THEY LIVE IN CALIFORNIA NOW.
AND THEY HAVE MADE PLENTY OF
WAVES IN, YOU KNOW, IN PLENTY
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY SAY
THEY'VE BEEN TAKING POT SHOTS AT
THE ROYAL FAMILY FROM AFAR.
BUT SINCE THE QUEEN'S PASSING,
THEY BELIEVE THAT PERHAPS THIS
MOMENT, PERHAPS THE QUEEN'S
DEATH COULD BE A MOMENT OF
RECONCILIATION BETWEEN THE
BROTHERS, THAT PERHAPS THEY
COULD HAVE SOME KIND OF
CONVERSATION.
THEY'RE TOGETHER FOR A PHOTO ON
RIGHT NOW, LOOKING THROUGH THE
CARDS AND FLOWERS LEFT FOR QUEEN
ELIZABETH.
SO IT MAY JUST BE A PHOTO
OPPORTUNITY, IT MAY BE SOMETHING
MORE.
THE OFFICIAL RESIDENCE, THE U.K.
RESIDENCE OF HARRY AND MEGHAN
WHICH IS FROG MORE COTTAGE,
ABOUT 600 YARDS FROM WHERE WILL
AND KATE, THE PRINCE AND
PRINCESS HAS JUST MOVED THEIR
FAMILY TO.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, ON THE SAME
DAY THAT QUEEN PASSED AWAYS WITH
THE KIDS FIRST OFFICIAL DAY AT
THEIR NEW SCHOOL, ONLY ABOUT 15
MINUTES OR SO FROM HERE.
AND AS THEY'RE LOOKING AT THESE
CARDS AND FLOWERS, I HAVE TO
TELL YOU, I'VE DONE THE SAME AND
READ THROUGH SOME OF THEM AND IT
IS PRETTY REMARKABLE.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE LEFT FULL PAGE
LETTERS AND NOTES TO THE
BOUQUETS AND YOU'VE HAD CHILDREN
MANY OF THEM WERE CLEARLY
WRITTEN BY CHILDREN AND
PICTURES.
ONE STANDS OUT TO ME IN
PARTICULAR IS SOMEONE HAD LEFT
TWO FULL CANS OF GIN AND TONIC
IN HONOR OF THE QUEEN.
AND MOST OF THEM, THERE SEEMS TO
BE A COMMON THEME IN A LOT OF
THESE NOTES THAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH AND READING RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT IS THAT THEY SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DUTY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CARRYING OUT
YOUR DUTIES RIGHT UNTIL THE END.
QUEEN WAS UNDENIABLY SEEN AS A
UNIFYING FIGURE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND MANY OF THESE VERY PERSONAL
EMOTIONAL CARDS AND NOTES
REFLECT THAT AS WELL.
SOME WISH THE NEW KING WELL.
I SHOULD ALSO POINT OUT HERE
THAT IF YOU HAD ANY DOUBT AT ALL
ABOUT JUST HOW IMPORTANT AND
JUST HOW CENTRAL THE MONARCHY IS
TO THIS COUNTRY, IT IS A GOOD
INDICATION.
BECAUSE THIS WAS NOT AN
ANNOUNCED OR ADVERTISED EVENT
THAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE.
IN FACT, THEY HAD TRIED THEIR
HARDEST TO SAY VERY LITTLE.
OF COURSE THERE ARE SOME
LOGISTICAL THINGS THAT COME WITH
ALLOWING THE HEIR TO THE THRONE
TO COME AND MINGLE WITH THE
PUBLIC SO THEY HAD TO SET UP
BARRICADES AND ABOUT TWO HOURS
AGO.
BUT BEYOND THAT, THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN WAITING HERE HAD NO
IDEA WHO MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
COMING.
WHY THEY MIGHT BE HERE.
BUT THEY'VE WAITED AROUND NOW
FOR QUITE SOMETIME, HOPING FOR A
GLIMPSE.
AND AS THEY SORT OF WALK DOWN
THE BARRICADES HERE, THIS IS
CALLED THE LONG WALK.
THIS IS OUTSIDE OF WINDSOR
CASTLE AND YOU COULD SEE THERE
ARE PEOPLE, MAYBE SIX OR SEVEN
PEOPLE DEEP JUST HOPING TO CATCH
ANY KIND OF A GLIMPSE OF THE
ROYALS.
OF COURSE, WE SAW KING CHARLES
MINGLED WITH THE CROWD OUTSIDE
OF BUCKINGHAM PALACE YESTERDAY.
WE SAW PRINCE ANDREW, AND PRINCE
EDWARD MINGLING WITH THE CROWD
OUTSIDE OF BALMORAL CASTLE IN
SCOTLAND TODAY AND OBVIOUSLY
THESE FOUR ARE THE OFFICIAL
RESIDENTS OF WINDSOR CASTLE.
SO IT IS NOT SURPRISING TO THEM
TO SEE THEM HERE.
EARLIER TODAY, AND MAX FOSTER
MENTIONED THIS, FREDRICKA, THERE
WAS AN OFFICIAL STATEMENT PUT
OUT BY KENSINGTON PALACE WRITTEN
BY THE PRINCE WILLIAM AND I JUST
WANT TO READ SOMETHING THAT
STOOD OUT TO ME IN THIS NOTE.
IT SAID I THANK HER ON BEHALF OF
MY GENERATION FOR PROVIDING AN
EXAMPLE OF SERVICE AND DIGNITY
IN PUBLIC LIFE THAT WAS FROM A
DIFFERENT AGE.
BUT ALWAYS RELEVANT TO US ALL.
AND HE GOES ON TO PROMISE THAT
HE WILL DO WHATEVER HE CAN TO
HONOR HER LEGACY BY TRYING TO
SUPPORT HIS FATHER, THE KING IN
ANY WAY THAT HE CAN.
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO MOVE DOWN
HERE IF WE CAN.
TO TRY TO GET A CLOSER LOOK.
WE'VE BEEN PUT IN THIS PRESS
PEN.
BUT IF WE COULD TRY TO MOVE DOWN
AND SEE IF WE COULD GET CLOSER
TO TRY TO HEAR, I THINK IT IS
HARRY AND MEGHAN THAT ARE ON
THIS SIDE OF THE BARRICADE, TO
TRY TO HEAR ANYTHING THAT THEY
MIGHT BE SAYING.
OF COURSE WE HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN
ANY OFFICIAL WORD ON THEIR
MOVEMENT, ACTUALLY, LET'S SEE IF
WE COULD GET THE CAMERA IN CLOSE
AND I'LL STOP TALKING AND PUT
THE MICROPHONE IN.
>> WE'RE TRY TO LISTEN IN,
SCOTT, REAL QUICK.
[ INAUDIBLE ].
>> SO IF YOUR JUST JOINING US,
THE PRINCE AND PRINCESS OF
WALES, WILLIAM AND KATE THERE,
HAVE COME OUT OF WINDSOR CASTLE.
THEY'RE INTERACTING WITH THE
HUNDREDS SEEMINGLY OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE THERE, TO MOURN THE PASSING
OF QUEEN ELIZABETH.
IT IS STARTED OUT BY THE TWO
BROTHERS HARRY AND WILLIAM AND
THEIR WIVES LOOKING AT FLOWERS
AND CARDS AND NOW THEIR
INTERACTED WITH THE PUBLIC AND
WE WANT TO LISTEN IN TO SEE IF
WE COULD HEAR SOME OF THAT
INTERACTION.
>> WE HAD SOME AUDIO THERE FOR A
MOMENT.
BUT YOU COULD HEAR.
I MEAN -- THERE WE COULD GO.
YOU COULD HEAR THERE ARE SOME
LAUGHTER AND A LOT OF SMILES.
THAT YOU COULD SEE IN THE CROWD,
YOU COULD SEE IN KATE THERE AS
WELL.
AND TOUCHING HER HEART AND
CLEARLY THEY WERE VERY MOVED BY
THE FLOWERS AND THE NOTES THAT
THEY JUST SCANNED RIGHT THERE AT
THE GATES.
OUR ROYAL CORRESPONDENT AND
ANCHOR MAX FOSTER ALSO WITH US
AGAIN, AS WELL AS HISTORIAN KATE
WILLIAMS.
SO MAX, TO YOU, THIS WAS WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND TO BE A VERY
SPONTANEOUS EVENT.
AT LEAST NONE OF US AND THE
PUBLIC DIDN'T SEEM TO KNOW THIS
WOULD HAPPEN.
HERE WE GO.
WITH THE TWO GRANDSONS AND THEIR
WIVES.
THIS IS PRETTY POIGNANT.
>> NOT THAT SPONTANEOUS, BUT
UNANNOUNCED BECAUSE OF THE
SECURITY CONCERNS HERE.
WHAT I WAS SURPRISED ABOUT IF
I'M HONEST IS SEEING THE
SUSSEXES THERE TOO.
THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY SEISMIC
MOMENTS OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
AND IF YOU IMAGINE THE SUSSEX
AND THE CAMBRIDGE, WAS HUGELY
UPSETTING TO THE QUEEN.
FOR US TO SEE MEGHAN AND HARRY
THERE REUNITED WITH KATE AND
WILLIAM IS A HUGE MOMENT.
AND HOPEFULLY A SIGN OF THINGS
TO COME AND RIFTS BEING HEALED
WITHIN THE FAMILY.
I MEAN, IT IS UTTERLY
PREOCCUPIED THE FAMILY.
THERE WAS TENSION BETWEEN HARRY
AND MEGHAN AND CHARLES AND THERE
WAS RESOLVED AROUND THE JUBILEE
WHEN THEY MET UP.
BUT THERE IS ONGOING TENSION
BETWEEN HARRY AND WILLIAM.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS RESOLVED
BUT IT IS RESOLVED TO COME OUT
TOGETHER IN PUBLIC TOGETHER.
THIS WILL GO DOWN WELL IN PUBLIC
BECAUSE WHENEVER ANYONE SAYS
ABOUT THE ROYAL FAMILY AND WHO
EVERYONE IS INTERESTED IN, IT IS
THE QUEEN THAT EVERYONE REVERED
AND THIS IS A HUGELY RESPECTFUL
THING TO DO FOR